at one of los angeles largest hospitals
covet 19 patients are packed
four to a room with only one nurse to
care for them
waiting rooms have become treatment
centers nearby
multiple hospital staff reposition
patients
so they can pull enough oxygen into
their lungs
it's likely to get worse going to see
another huge surge upon surge
it will happen in the next seven to ten
days some are describing it
as a viral tsunami across the u.s more
than 100 thousand people have been
hospitalized with covid
for the past 40 days in a row across the
country
mass vaccination centers are being set
up
including at disneyland and dodger
stadium in southern california
at a sports complex near fort worth
texas
and a football stadium outside of boston
massachusetts
glad plans to start out doing 300
vaccines per day but is going to build
up to administering
five thousand vaccines per day so far
the vaccination program has been slower
than expected
and with no nationwide plan in place
often haphazard
early tuesday morning in north carolina
hundreds of elderly people waited for
hours at a drive-through vaccination
center
but many of them were turned away when
supplies ran out
the trump administration announced on
tuesday it would no longer hold back
millions of vaccine doses
it had been reserving for second shots
every vaccine dose that is sitting in a
warehouse rather than going into an
armed
could mean one more life lost or one
more hospital bed
occupied the about face came days after
president-elect
joe biden said he would do the same
thing once he takes office
covet 19 has infected several gorillas
at the san diego zoo safari park
the first known transmission to great
apes the guerrillas tested positive
after they began
coughing officials believe an
asymptomatic zoo
staffer unwittingly gave them the virus
they're doing okay
they're they're experiencing some mild
symptoms and we continue to observe
them but they're drinking they're eating
and they're interacting with one another
zoo veterinarians expect the gorillas to
make a full recovery
but more than 376 thousand americans
have now
died from covet 19. rob reynolds al
jazeera los angeles